those willing to squeeze into this bus
have made a choice
not just to leave russian occupied
curson
but to leave nearly everything they have
they cling to only their most precious
things
there wasn't room for much
the journey to the ukrainian hell town
of bashtanka meant crossing the front
lines but
that was like nightmare really because
it's really horrible it's like i'm
blinking all the time
i see you don't have much in the way of
baggage what have you left behind
for the whole life
my favorite stuff are all pets we had to
leave them with my parents
we had to leave my parents there my
sister and my niece
she says life is dangerous in her song
people get taken do you mean taking them
from their homes from their homes from
their streets from their work
whatever so people are disappearing yes
little information comes out from the
area
some said they waited a month for their
chance to get out
this was really hard a lot of
food supplies meant which we need to
live a normal way a normal life we just
can't get it there are not many drivers
who are willing to shuttle across enemy
lines but yuri says he's made the trip
twice a day for the last month and the
russians don't mind me
they said we don't hold anyone you can
leave we'll just change the lock on your
door and crimean people from villages
will come and live in her son and there
will be a her son people's republic
four and a half million people have fled
ukraine since the conflict began and
like two million of them anastasia susha
and maria will head to poland
but this small town of bush tanka isn't
safe
many fled from here when the russians
tried to take the town last month
destroying homes
the bombs that created these two craters
have crushed completely three houses and
also taken the rules as i look around me
off one two three four five six
seven houses but surprisingly when the
russians tried to invade this small town
they were pushed back
the talk in town is of russians massing
for another attempt and pregnant mother
of six urina doesn't know what to do
i'm worried i don't know where to go
when we hear the explosions i'm scared
it will hit us because there are many
people and children
for some this is home
for others the first staging post in a
journey to an uncertain future
stay or go is the question for so many
but for yuri there's only one choice
to go back for more
jason farrell sky news bash tanker